all morning we're following the
destructive path of hurricane laura the
storm
is providing a wealth of information for
the scientists known as storm
chasers the organization hurricane track
set up a series of locked down
cameras across louisiana and texas
documenting laura as it made landfall
and then moved
inland storm chasers followed laura's
impact on cities across the gulf coast
including lake charles omar villafranca
is there right now
omar these folks put cameras in places
you do not want to see
now that the sun is up what are what are
you seeing
well we're starting to see some of the
debris that fell off obviously the
buildings and it was blown around
there's water covering everything once
it's safe we're going to be able to go
out and try to see what the storm did
overnight in the cover of darkness now
when the storm was blowing in earlier
and the winds were much higher
going out to get that video in all
honesty it's too dangerous for the crew
david tracy rodney all the
everybody who's here with me we don't
want to be out in that because you can
really get hurt
but there's other video that you're
about to see that doesn't involve a
person it's just a box and a camera and
in that video
you can see the wrath of the storm as it
came ashore
and basically kept this kept us locked
down
for hours from lake charles louisiana to
port arthur texas
and multiple other points in the gulf
coast storm chaser mark seduth has his
eyes
and ears on the path of hurricane
laura's destruction
what we're seeing is that all the
predictions are coming true of a very
dangerous hurricane especially happening
at night
we've already seen damage in lake
charles lots of power outages
and very very high wind the camera is
able to capture these
the storm surge completely submerged one
camera as it was shooting along the
coast
in cameron louisiana the water hit the
camera and we figured oh wow at that
point the water had risen
at least nine feet another camera in
lake charles fell victim to the high
winds
well we had mounted the camera actually
on a palm tree
and i think that the roots just didn't
go down far enough into the sand
we first spoke with sedup before the
storm made landfall
these cameras will show us the storm
surge
show us the wind from a fixed location
where somebody like you we can't stand
out there and do it ourselves
because even the most hardy storm
chasers
have their limits these take the place
of that to show us what's going on in
real time
oh my goodness so that's organization
hurricane track
has been recording and studying these
massive storms
for decades you guys saw the roof come
off the building
including katrina in 2005.
wilma that same year and ike in 2008.
what do scientists learn in this video
the video serves the purpose of showing
us what's going on we obviously want to
see
but from a scientific perspective how
fast did the storm surge come up
what was some of the force of the storm
surge
how fast was the wind blowing sadath
says hurricane laura
is already among the strongest he's seen
one of the most astounding things
and surprising elements of laura is the
intensity
laura strengthened like it did to almost
category five
intensity that's rare
sadath also said he set up a camera in
shreveport so he could
which is farther north so he could see
the storm as it crisscrossed the state
now he learns a lot from watching the
video as it's happening but he says
that once he downloads that video
there's so much more he can learn about
the strength of the storms
but the big problem gail is he has to go
and
find those and after a storm like this
and all the winds whipping around
he may lose a camera or two better a
camera too
as opposed to a life or a limb why does
he say he does it omar
just to educate the rest of us for the
thrill of it all of the above
all i mean he he does make a little
money off it but
he's he's just one of those weather
geeks i mean
you look at the hashtag whatever state
you know hashtag
l-a-w-x louisiana weather people are
going to be looking at it he's just one
of those guys that wants to
learn and share that information and
let's be honest us as news organizations
we want to see it too yeah we're
grateful yeah i was going to say
we're very grateful very appreciative
and he's giving us a lot of very
useful information that we could use and
that the experts can use too
to maybe be better prepared for the next
time because there's always a next time
when it comes to this situation omar
thank you very much you stay safe too
omar
we want you to be okay along with the
rest of your crew we like you in this
building all right thank you